since the start of the pandemic
test and trace has done 900 million
tests and contacted
2.5 million people impressive feats
but as a new report by mps points out
not enough to stop lockdown despite
eye-watering costs
you can't say that the failure to
prevent lockdowns is down just to test
and trace but clearly there are many
government decisions about lifting
lockdowns things like the christmas
uh mixing that was still allowed so the
government overall has to take full
responsibility for the fact that it went
into lockdowns late
and it didn't deliver on those and if it
was relying only on test and trace to
prevent those that wasn't enough
but test and trace was clearly a part of
that and the justification
for the billions of pounds spent on it
was partly to avoid those future
lockdowns
test and trace was originally given 22
billion pounds for this year
then in last week's budget rishi sunak
added another 15 billion
taking its total budget to 37 billion
over two years
some former senior civil servants say is
vast
that's about the same amount of money
that we spend on our entire
public safety system so that's the
police the criminal courts the prisons
that's what you buy for 37 billion
pounds
that money bought all those tests but
also consultants paid 1 000
pounds a day and a contact tracing app
that's been used for more than a hundred
million check-ins
but we revealed last week only
287 venue alerts
the head of test and trace defended its
work
we do and have done more tests per 100
000 of the population than any other
comparable country in europe just
yesterday 1.5 million tests were
conducted
as our children go back to school we
should be proud of that
that's a success story school testing
the next frontier for test and trace in
england
let's hope it's effective enough to
justify that budget
sky news